he just gonna have fun oh she is
Jojo see hua has been killing the
quarantine tick-tock game pretty much
yes the YouTube star broke the internet
when she celebrated her 17th birthday by
posting this
white light wipe it down why yep that's
Jojo literally wiping away her signature
side ponytail white she started the
video with her usual thick completed
with a sequined puffer jacket then BOOM
the dance are transformed into her new
look rocking a Gucci t-shirt and her
long blond locks that's me that's me the
video reached 29 point 5 million views
and girl was totally feeling herself
right wipe it why even in quarantine she
still managed to throw herself an
over-the-top a Jojo C wat themed
birthday party just a casual flex filled
with balloons ice cream and of course
dancing and the dancing doesn't stop on
tick-tock Jojo made a huge splash while
showing off her moves to Rihanna's
Umbrella
the seventeen-year-old absolutely
crushed it totally which is why she has
fun with her makeup - Jojo gave fans a
tutorial on how to do her signature
makeup glitter and all and in quarantine
Jojo has been tick-tocking all over her
candy land theme Taos okay guys use this
sound if you have something you want to
show off in your room that no one else
probably has from showing off her
bedroom that has over 4,000 pounds of
candy in it it's pretty awesome
whew her candy themed game room the 17
year old has racked up twenty two point
seven million followers on tik tok ET
talked to Jojo back in 2017 about her
rising thing people looking up to me
people say that I inspire them like it's
so amazing for me to see that it's just
like wow like it's unbelievable
[Music]
you